antimatter is the most potent fuel
source known to humanity
and it could be the secret to faster
than light space travel
but
where in the universe would we find
antimatter
how fast could it make your spaceship
travel
and why would you want to stock up on
bananas on your intergalactic trip
this is what if and here's what would
happen if you could power a spaceship
with antimatter
every particle of matter created in the
big bang has an equal and opposite
particle of antimatter
theoretically
these antimatter particles have the same
mass and lifetime as the regular matter
particles
only they have a different electric
charge
and if antimatter ever came in contact
with regular matter
there would be a big boom
the particles would annihilate each
other and this would produce energy
lots of it
this destruction of particles could be
about 10 billion times more powerful
than chemical combustion or around 1 000
times more powerful than nuclear fission
for a trip to mars you'd only need an
amount of antimatter equal to about 1 1
000 of an m m
so let's grab some and hit the road
but wait
where is it
imagine you were aiming for the closest
star system alpha centauri with current
chemical based fuels that trip would
take you about 30 000 years
using a rocket propelled by antimatter
though you could really crank up the
speed
you could zip through space at 116
million kilometers per hour
or as some promising studies would
suggest maybe as fast as 72 percent the
speed of light that would make the
journey to alpha centauri a mere six
years
okay so what are you waiting for if
matter and antimatter particles were
both created in our early universe as a
pair
finding antimatter should be pretty
simple right
well think again
researchers have struggled to find much
antimatter anywhere
but that doesn't mean that producing our
own antimatter would be completely out
of the question
scientists have observed antimatter
production in cern's particle
accelerator experiments and during
thunderstorms
even
wait for it in one of your favorite
fruits
the energy density of antimatter is so
high that you wouldn't need very much in
order to harness a lot of power
one gram would be as powerful as a
nuclear bomb
except that making this much antimatter
would cost over 1 quadrillion dollars
so with a price tag like that
you shouldn't be surprised to learn that
the amount of antimatter we've managed
to produce at this point wouldn't be
enough to boil a cup of water let alone
get us into space
and if we did manage to produce this
antimatter you'd face another challenge
ordinary matter and antimatter need to
be separated
otherwise they'd annihilate each other
remember
your spaceship would need to be equipped
with magnetic storage rings that would
be able to keep the antimatter separate
until it's needed
then you'd be able to redirect some of
the antimatter to produce thrust
alternatively you could base your rocket
on the anti-particles of electrons
called positrons
you'd just need to equip your ship with
a source that continuously emits
positrons as its isotopes decay
such as
krypton once emitted these positrons are
hotter than the core of the sun
but if you could keep them cool while
you extract them you'd be on board one
fast ship
a single loop around earth would take
just three seconds and a trip to mars
would only take you a couple weeks
and should you ever run out of your
krypton isotope source
your backup positron source would be no
further away than the nearest fruit bowl
yeah that's right there's antimatter in
bananas
that's bananas
bananas contain small amounts of
potassium 40 which is a naturally
occurring isotope of yeah you guessed it
potassium
as it decays it produces one positron
about every 75 minutes
now no matter what source of antimatter
you chose to use there would be some
significant dangers to keep an eye out
for
the reaction between matter and
antimatter would produce enormous
amounts of high energy gamma radiation
this would be extremely dangerous and
could damage your dna so you'd need to
find a way to protect yourself from
something that can penetrate almost
anything
and you'd have to make sure the
anti-matter containment is never
breached
maybe one or two positrons from a banana
wouldn't kill you but the more reactions
that occur
the more likely your own annihilation
would become
you wouldn't want to be the one
responsible for accidentally detonating
an anti-matter bomb here on earth would
you
well
that's a story
for another
what if
you